hey everyone welcome back to round four
of the dubai rapid tournament
if you watch the first three games
you'll know that i started with three
wins
my opponent's uh progressively getting
stronger as i win more games
and in round four i'm playing an
international master
with a rating of 2067
which is a little bit low rated for an
im but the tournament was using rapid
ratings
so that could have something to do with
it and going into this game i knew my
opponent was a french defense player
again i had time to find my opponent's
chest.com username beforehand and find
out generally what openings uh my phone
plays
and i knew to expect e4 and e6
and i was debating what to go for
because there's a lot of different
things i can play against the french
between mainline terrash the two knights
attack
uh the exchange variation the wing
gambit which is knight f3
this is this and b4
um there's b3 which is kind of an
interesting sideline
but i decided that
i would go for an opening which i've
actually never played over the board
which is the ortho schnapp gambit
and this opening starts with c4
d5
cd5 ed5 and queen b3 and before maybe
about a year ago this line was virtually
unknown
but uh it actually all started with uh
jonathan schrantz who's a fellow chess
youtuber
he made a video covering this variation
and then i adopted this variation to
play in my streams and blitz and bullets
and it's a surprisingly interesting and
venomous line
especially against french defense
players who normally like closed and
more kind of methodical positional games
this is a line to guarantee
a more open and tactical battle
which
french defense players may not be so
comfortable with
so first of all this is a gambit
white is sacrificing a pawn uh my
opponent accepted the gambit by taking
the alternative for black heroes to play
knife six
after which i would play e5 and if
knight e4 i would play d4 and we would
get
maybe a structure that resembles more of
a french
but after pawn takes pawn the game
changes style
and now it's up to white to try and
improve compensation
and i go for bishop c4 developing with
tempo
creating the battery against f7 pawn and
here black has to do something a little
bit awkward to defend the pawn there's
really not too many options other than
moving the queen either to f6 e7 or d7
now i should note queen f6 walks into
knight c3
after which white has more initiative
and this is already looking very
pleasant for white
so the two main moves here are queen e7
and queen d7 a bone play queen e7 which
is a very fine move
i continue knight to c3
and now in i have six
a very natural move
i should note here an alternative for
black is to play c6
and
i'll admit i haven't studied like too
many specific ortho schnapp lines i just
know basic ideas but one line to know is
c6 with idea of trying to target the
bishop
and after this i would play pawn to d3
accepting the fact that black can trap
the bishop
but if b5 there's a nice idea to take
takes and bishop d5
and white is winning back some material
with the rook attacked
there are some lines to further
investigate like bishop b7 and queen b5
but
white is coming back here and there's
less to worry about
so
my opponent didn't go for c6 instead
went for knight f6
and i still play d3 and the point of d3
is to temporarily sacrifice another pawn
and if black were to take it
white can continue with accelerating
development
already ready to castle queenside
and okay this pawn's a goner
and if white can have such nice
development and win back the pawn
uh meanwhile black is
very underdeveloped very slow to get the
king castled
there should be enough compensation here
instead what happened the game my
opponent played knight to c6 clearly
aiming for some
knight move to exploit the placement of
my queen i take back
and here my opponent plays knight d4
which turned out to be another kind of
slight mistake
given my next move
what black should do here is take
the pawn
and i wouldn't be able to take back
because after it takes takes
g2 would be hit
and
some knight e5 move could be coming
so i would play bishop e3
here the the engine actually gives a big
plus for black after knight c5
um so things could have gone very bad
for me very quickly
if my opponent played a few accurate
moves in the opening
that's one of the risks with playing
such a gambit is
it could backfire
but
opponent didn't play perfectly
played knight d4
and now after queen a4 there's a few
things for black to worry about
and my opponent pretty quickly played
bishop d7
probably missing my tactical idea is to
exploit the knight on d4 it's an
undefended piece
aligned with my queen
and i was very happy to snag the pawn on
f7 and after king f7 queen d4
even though i'm the one who played the
gambit
i'm actually up a pawn here because i
won the one back the pawn on e4
and now on the pawn on f7
and things uh get really bad for black
really quickly from here
so
instead of bishop d7 my opponent should
have seen the danger and play the move
like queen d7
and from here okay the game is still
very much a fight
but what happens okay i won the pawn won
the knights
opponent plays rook to e8
trying to pressure the e-file
i simply develop
and here my opponent made a very very
bad blunder
and took the pawn
even though there are three attackers
and only two defenders
when black takes the pawn
i take back and the queen is overworked
the queen is busy defending the bishop
and there's not really time to take my
knight because the bishop would be
hanging so after takes takes
white is just up a clean piece here
my opponent realized this
and was clearly
just disappointed at the board
black just gave away a night for a pawn
and
from here the game ended in just a few
more moves
opponent went for bishop to c6
uh targeting the diagonal trying to
create some counterplay
but i have
some initiative of my own i start with
queen c4 hitting the king
there's not a great way to get out of
check if queen e6
i put the hammer down with a fork on g5
so black here had to play king g6
and here i very simply move back to c3
realizing that if bishop takes g2
i can then play queen g4 and pick off
the bishop
so after knight c3 everything is pretty
much covered for whites opponent tried
queen b4 but i was happy to trade queens
and here even though my pawn is still
attacked i'm able to defend it with
tactics and play knight to e2
uh making it so black can't take it
because if bishop g2
i actually have the option of pinning or
forking
so the pawn is
untouchable and
my opponent actually resigned in this
position
white's just off a clean piece black
doesn't even have a pawn for it
and uh yeah from here it would be a
pretty simple conversion
so that was my round four game out of
all the games up until this point
this is probably the the easiest game
the shortest game
one in just 17 moves
so i was feeling pretty good
to start the tournament with four out of
four
so i hope you enjoyed this one it was a
bit quicker than usual but uh hopefully
there is a lesson or two to take away
and stay tuned for my round five game
i don't want to give too much away but
in round five i do play
grandmaster top seed
and we
we fought for the lead in the tournament
so stay tuned for that
be sure to like and subscribe
and of course if you have any questions
leave them in the comments
and i'll see you in the next video